let's go to d baby from is it alsace i i
don't know that i'm pronouncing any of
these things correctly
d baby are you there it's it's all space
can you can you hear me yes i can
yes it it's it's alsace alsace where is
alsace
oh it's on the on the border of uh
france oh okay beautiful what's on your
mind d baby
well you know i've just uh
i've just been a been a little a little
little down lately
you know it just uh
just feels like we keep
we keep uh you know
this this inching inching progress
forward you know
it just feels like it's it's you know
one step forward five steps back
half a step forward eight steps back
i don't know it just it just seems like
we're we're going down i don't i don't
know do you do you have any
any sort of sort of uh any sort of
feeling that we're uh you know that this
trend is gonna change are we having can
you give me some examples of the steps
forward and the steps back so i would
know what you mean
i mean i mean it it just
uh i
i guess i guess one way to think of it
is sort of if you look at what's
happening with inflation right now
you know like uh we we just
all these
d baby thank you appreciate the call